what was exciting was taking the
original Meg and then supercharging it
and giving it bigger creatures bigger
monsters that's the biggest snake I've
ever seen
station you can make it keep going
Jason Statham is perfect for this one I
got this Statham's a great Action Hero
he's just a quintessential badass
see you later
three massive Megs and who knows what
else have escaped the breach there's a
team of them now at any turn a Megalodon
could jump out at you we've never seen
this before they hunted it backs
oh
there's a Maelstrom of enemies it's like
Jurassic Park underwater yeah bring it
on let's get more creatures from the
deep it is sheer aquatic chaos and it's
awesome this is going to be megalodonish
[Music]
thank you